Atop Earth’s highest mountain above sea
level hardly seems like an easy place to live.
Mount Everest’s tall peaks, freezing temperatures,
fierce winds, and ever-present snow make it
hard to support life.
And while it’s true that very few plants
or animals can survive there, the most famous
resident certainly seems at home—the Yeti.
The huge, hairy monster has been spotted walking
across Asian mountains from China to the Himalayas.
Some say it looks like an ape, others a bear,
and others even insist it’s an unidentified
humanoid species.
The first reports of a “wild man” in the
Himalayas in the Western word appear during the
19th century– but didn’t really get much attention.
But in the 20th century a few expeditions,
some reported tracks, and one very famous
photograph began a crazed hunt for the Yeti.
[Monstrum intro]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka, and this is Monstrum.
It’s generally believed Yeti is a mispronunciation
of the word yeh teh from Tibetan Sherpa dialect,
meaning either “cliff dwelling bear” or
“animal of rocky places.”
Regardless, when you hear “yeti” you probably
picture the huge creature with fluffy white
fur that pops up in movies all the time —the
one commonly called the “Abominable Snowman”.
"Abominable! Can you believe that?
Do I look abominable to you?"
But there’s no real folklore that supports
that version before the 20th century.
Written accounts of the Tibetan legend of
the yeti date back to the 12th century.
Also called a “wild man,” many
accounts describe the creature as an ape-like
being, over six feet tall walking on its back legs
with reddish-brown fur covering its muscular body.
Explanations range from a real animal displaced
in search of food, to a purely fictional folklore
creature.
Tibetan tradition recognizes a variety of
yeti.
One said to walk on two legs,
and another larger yeti
that preys on livestock, and walks on four legs.
Yeti are believed to live in the alpine forests
below the snow line, although they will brave
higher altitude for food and shelter.
They don’t eat or hunt humans (although
they may steal food from them), preferring
the mosses, frogs, and pikas that live on
the mountain.
In many stories, the yeti is nocturnal and
emits a high-pitched screech or whistle; in
Tibetan tradition, it is more common to hear
a yeti then to see one.
The two-legged meh teh appears in Buddhist
temple decorations and religious painted scrolls.
According to a religious and historical Tibetan
text from the 12th century
these “wild people” and humans come from
shared ancestors, although the meh teh is
neither fully human nor fully animal.
This is why much of the art in Tibetan temples
shows the “yeti realm” of rebirth between
humans and animals.
And Tibetan Buddhist stories feature yetis
as both kind and malevolent characters.
One popular tale from the Himalayas tells
of an injured yogi helping a “wild man”
with an infected foot from a splinter.
The yogi kindly removes the splinter and cleans
the wound.
The grateful yeti thanks the yogi by bringing
him a tiger, which the man skins and offers
to a monastery.
Legends are often born when we blur the lines
between fiction and real life events.
In the 17th-century, a Buddhist religious
leader [Lama Sangwa Dorje] walked from India
to Nepal to reside in a cave as a religious
hermit.
While living there, he claimed friendly yetis
would bring him food and water, allowing him
a life of quiet meditation.
When one of the yetis died, he kept the scalp
as a holy relic in the temple he built in 1667.
This real-life relic became a part of blessing
rituals for the temple monks.
Later, a yeti hand was added to the collection,
another tribute to the creatures that made
the temple possible.
The temple monks refused to allow anyone to
remove the relics for hundreds of years, but
in 1959, explorer Peter Byrne stole a few
finger bones from the hand, substituting them
with human ones.
So, yeti legends and stories were culturally
important long before the Western world was
even aware of their existence.
In reality, the yeti entered into Western
thought as a footnote.
Literally, a footnote in a book.
In 1832 British naturalist Brian H. Hodgson
writing about mammals in Nepal,
noted that no monkeys could be found in the
northern and central regions, BUT a footnote
mentioned that during one expedition frightened
local shooters fled what they believed to
be a “wild man.”
He was told the creature moved upright, was
covered with long dark hair, and had no tail.
Still no monkeys, but the tale of the curious
humanoid gave Hodgson pause.
In 1889, the first mention of yeti footprints
appeared in “Among the Himalayas”, by
British explorer Laurence A Waddel.
He writes that according to Tibetans the large
tracks were made by what they identified as
“hairy wild men who are believed to live
amongst the eternal snows.”
At the turn of the 20th Century, the first
exploration and hunting parties descended
on the Himalayas in search of the mysterious,
hairy “wild man.”
But it wasn’t until Lieutenant Colonel Charles
Howard-Bury’s 1921 Mt. Everest exploration
that the press started to pay attention.
Howard-Bury and five others saw tracks in
the snow that they could not identify. Local
laborers accompanying them identified the tracks
as belonging to “the Wild Man of the Snows."
Howard-Bury believed the prints in the snow
were from a grey wolf, but when he and his
team were interviewed by journalist Henry
Newman, the reporter found no excitement in
that explanation and instead focused on the
Tibetan “boogey man” with his backward
facing feet and long matted hair.
He mistranslated Metoh-Kangmi, which roughly
means “man-bear snow-man,” as “filthy
snow-man” which he decided sounded better
as “abominable snowman.”
Something about the name captured the public’s
imagination and interest in the creature snowballed.
But expeditions to search for the yeti became
difficult because of political and religious
tensions after China invaded Tibet, leading
to thousands of deaths.
Until in 1951, an agreement was made affirming
China’s sovereignty over Tibet but allowing
their political system to remain unchanged
and religious freedom to stay protected--including
the belief in the the meh teh.
With a more stable political climate, explorers
once again poured in to hunt for the monster. Most
notable was the 1951 Mount Everest Reconnaissance
Expedition led by Eric Shipton, which produced
the single most famous piece of yeti evidence—a
photograph of a footprint.
Dubbed the “Shipton print,” the widely
published photo shows a huge human-like footprint
in the snow reportedly discovered on Mount
Everest at 18,000 feet.
It was printed everywhere.
Newspapers, science journals, and popular
magazines around the world plastered it across
their pages.
In 1952, a year after Shipton’s famous photograph,
a Swiss exploration team found possible Yeti
tracks at 16,000 feet.
A porter even claimed to be attacked by a
Yeti... buttt the rest of the team didn’t
corroborate his story.
The monster search craze reached such a level
that the Nepalese government, seeing an opportunity
to exploit Yeti, began offering special
Yeti hunting licenses.
In 1954 the popular British newspaper The
Daily Mail funded a Himalayan Yeti-finding
expedition.
Texas oilman and monster hunter Tom Slick
also threw his cowboy hat into the ring.
His bio included hunts for Bigfoot and the
Loch Ness Monster.
In the 1950’s, he dedicated three expeditions
to the yeti, and Life Magazine offered him
$25,000 for the rights to any photos he took
of the creature.
After 1959, tensions in the area came to a
head again, and a Tibetan uprising led to
a Chinese crack-down on Yeti expeditions for
fear of espionage.
For a decade, it was difficult to travel into
the country to look for the Yeti, but two
expeditions managed to wiggle through the
cracks.
Between 1960 and 1961 Edmund Hillary and Marlin
Perkins led expeditions with a team of scientists
who examined the infamous yeti relic hand,
and ID’ed it as coming from a modern human,
although at the time they didn’t know Byrne
had swapped out the finger bones.
Shockingly, the monks at the temple also allowed
them to take the famous yeti scalp—but only
if one of their elders could accompany it,
using the opportunity to raise money to build
schools in Nepal.
In 1960, separate examinations of the scalp
in London, Chicago, and Paris found that is
was a fake relic made from serow flesh.
The discovery appeared to dampen the spirits
of yeti hunters and expeditions began to wane.
None of the expeditions were able to bring
back conclusive evidence of a Yeti.
Enter Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer, the
1964 Christmas television special, whose
fluffy white, arguably adorable yeti
reignited the popularity.
The fanged, white, furry character with blue
hands and feet at first seems scary, until
it’s revealed that it’s only suffering
from a toothache.
The character, Bumble, is explicitly called
an “abominable snow monster.”
It’s my opinion this is the thing that created
the white-haired snow monster Westerners identify
as a yeti, the one most often seen in pop
culture today.
In the 70s, the Chinese government sent more
than 100 people to investigate the Yeti.
After they found nothing, they even allowed
Western expeditions into Tibet again but those
didn’t reveal anything either.
In the same decade, the famous Shipton photograph
became widely viewed as a fake.
One team member of the 1951expedition even
told a journalist that it was very possible
the photo was a hoax given that Shipton “definitely
liked to take the mickey out of people”
and “would think that was quite a good joke.”
But some of the expeditions over the years
did return with more than photos.
Newly discovered fragments of bones, skin,
teeth, and fecal matter were all brought back
and investigated, but nothing conclusive developed.
It seems that every time some new scientific
insight attempts to answer, “Is the yeti
real?” the world pays attention.
Take the Bhutan discovery for example.
In 2001, a British zoologist collected
a few strands of hair from a hollow
cedar tree in Bhutan.
Under DNA analysis, the hair could not be
identified as coming from any animal known
to science.
Was this conclusive proof that some yet-unidentified
creature lived in the Himalayas?
Not exactly. In 2014, yeti made the news again
when a study showed that the hair actually
came from an extinct paleolithic polar bear.
In 2017, a team of scientists analyzed another
24 supposed yeti specimens taken from the
Himalayas and Tibetan Plateau, including bone,
tooth, skin, hair, and fecal samples.
All but one of the samples (which came
from a dog) were from bears,
including Himalayan bears who
occupy the northwestern plateau.
Himalayan bears have paler, reddish-brown
fur, which seems awfully like the hair in
the descriptions of the original Tibetan yetis.
Interestingly, the scientists discovered that
the Himalayan brown bear came from a unique
evolutionary lineage that diverged from all
other brown bears around 650,000 years ago.
So, in their report, the scientists say that
the study’s findings “strongly suggest”
that yeti’s are based on local brown and
black bears.
I happen to agree.
Bears also play a really important role in
Tibetan mythology and lore.
There’s belief in a half-human and half-brown
bear creature called the mi-dred.
In Upper Tibet among the Chinese Na-khi  people,
apes, marmots, brown bears, and mi-dred
are “the four brothers who are like humans
but are not human.”
They were believed to have the same ancestry
because they are all capable of standing on
their back legs.
Folklore tells of brown bears abducting women
and producing children with them, and of brown
bears leaving human footprints.
Tibetan folklore, religion, scientific discoveries,
there’s actually a lot going on with this
monster—it’s kind of amazing.
Both the snarling, bloodthirsty yeti
we see in some depictions
and the kinder, helpful versions we see in others
have some basis in Himalyan
folklore, but ultimately they only touch the
surface.
The more dangerous representations promote
a healthy sense of wariness around bears,
or serve as warnings of the very real dangers
of the snow and high altitude.
And the kinder, helpful versions of the yeti
speak to the Buddist belief that all living
things have a purpose and a place in the world.
Around 65,000 years ago.
6,500 thousand years ago. Right?
"650,000--"
-Holy Moly! 6,500,000!
"650,000."
Six-- [deep breath] 650,000. Wow.